This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Sophie.
And I'm Neil. I was watching the news the other day Sophie.
Learn anything interesting?
Yes actually. UK scientists have been authorised by the government
to genetically modify human embryos for research.
What they can't do though is implant modified embryos into women.
They talked a lot about gene editing.
Can you explain to us what gene editing is?
Um, I think this means there are these letters in a code,
A, B, C, something. I can't remember exactly.
Gene editing is the ability to manipulate or control DNA.
And in case you didn't know, DNA is short for
Deoxyribonuclic Acid.
This is a substance in the cells of animals and plants
that contains genetic information.
And a gene is part of the DNA in the cell that controls
the physical development and behaviour of a plant
or animal and is passed on from its parents.
Phew, thanks for the science lesson Sophie.
You're welcome.
Now here's a question for you.
Which science fiction film anticipates gene editing
in a dystopian society where humans are genetically engineered?
Is it a Robocop?
B, Gatica or C, Blade Runner?
Hmm, I don't really understand the question,
but I'm going to say C, Blade Runner.
What's dystopian?
Dystopian means an imaginary society
where people aren't happy and afraid.
Well, moving on, let's listen to BBC Journalist
Fergus Walsh talking about how gene editing works.
Think of gene editing as a molecular satnav.
It scans the DNA searching for the error.
Then it uses molecular scissors to snip through both strands
which switches off the faulty gene.
Or it can repair the code by inserting a healthy copy of the gene.
These techniques raise the prospect of treating
even curing some genetic diseases.
And it's not science fiction.
So DNA is a set of instructions for how our bodies work.
Written using a chemical code of four letters,
A, T, C, G.
But sometimes the code contains mistakes.
Yes, you find spelling mistakes by scanning
or searching through the DNA.
Then you snip or cut out the mistake
or faulty gene from the code using molecular scissors.
Faulty, by the way, means something that isn't working properly.
Like the faulty breaks on my bike.
That sounds really dangerous, Neil.
Yeah, but I'm more worried about my faulty genes.
I might have all sorts of genetic mistakes inside me.
That wouldn't surprise me.
But you've actually touched on a serious point.
Latest research suggests all our bodies
do contain genetic mistakes,
some of which could cause disease.
And as reporter Fergus Walsh said at the end of the clip,
gene editing could be important for treating
or even curing inherited genetic diseases.
For patients with blood, immune, muscle or skin disorders,
it offers the possibility that their faulty cells
could be removed or changed in the lab and then put back.
That does sound amazing, but is there a catch?
And that means a problem or drawback.
Yes, some people think that if editing the genes
of a human embryo is allowed for curing disease,
this will lead to editing the genes of embryos
for reasons other than health.
Let's listen to Marcy Dinovsky,
Executive Director of the Center for Genetics
and Society in California,
talking about her concerns.
It's too risky.
We don't need it.
There are other ways to have healthy children.
And it would open the door, possibly,
to a world of genetic calves and have knots.
We don't need more inequality.
We don't need more discrimination in the world.
An embryo, by the way, is an animal or human
starting to develop inside its mother.
Marcy Dinovsky is against gene editing
because it may be used to create designer babies
or babies whose genes have been selected
to have certain desirable characteristics.
She says it may open the door or make it possible,
a situation where embryos are genetically enhanced
or improved to be more intelligent
or physically stronger, for example.
And this will lead to more discrimination in the world,
which means treating some people less fairly than others.
Which is something that science fiction
has been predicting for many years.
It's that dystopian society we were discussing earlier, Neil.
Which science-fiction film anticipates
gene editing in a dystopian society
where humans are genetically engineered?
Is it a Robocop, B, Gatica,
or C, Blade Runner?
And I said C, Blade Runner.
Sorry, Neil.
It was B, Gatica.
This 1997 sci-fi film
centers on the character Vincent Freeman,
who wasn't genetically engineered,
but is able to buy the genetic identity of another man
in order to pursue his dream of traveling into space.
The film's title uses the letters
G, A, T, and C, which are the four chemical codes
making up DNA.
Now, here are today's words, gene editing.
Manipulate, DNA, gene dystopian, scanning,
snip, faulty, catch embryo.
Designer babies, open the door,
enhanced discrimination.
Well, that's the end of today's 6 Minute English.
Please do join us again soon.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye.